a very warm welcome to all our viewers
this is Anjali from simply learn and
today we will be looking at the
installation for the tool chef as you
probably already know chef is a
configuration management tool so that
basically means that chef is a tool
which can automate the entire process of
configuring multiple systems it also
comes with a variety of other
functionalities which you can check out
in our video on water chef and the chef
tutorial so before we move on to the
installation process let me just explain
to you in brief the architecture of chef
so chef has three components
there's the workstation which is where
the system admin sits and he or she
writes the configuration files here your
second system is the server the server
is where all these configuration files
are stored and finally you have the
client or the node systems so these are
the systems that require the
configuration you can have any number of
clients but for a demo to keep it simple
we'll just have one client now I'm using
my Oracle VM VirtualBox manager as you
can see here I'll have two machines the
master and the node both of these are
sent to as seven machines as of the
server we'll be using this as a service
on the cloud so let's begin let's have a
look at a master system first this my
master system the terminals open over
here and the terminal color here it's
black background with green text and
this is my node system so the terminal
here has a black background with white
text so you can differentiate between
the both so we start at our master
system the first thing we need to do is
we need to download the chef DK so you
can write W get which is the command for
downloading and then go to your browser
and just type chef DK here
the first link
so here you have different versions of
chef DK depending on the operating
system that you are using you need to
select the appropriate one I'm using the
Red Hat Enterprise version and that's
number seven so I'm using Center as
seven so this is my link for downloading
chef TK just copy this link and go back
to your terminal and paste it here so
your chef DK is being downloaded this
will take a while
right after we download the chef DK our
next step is to install it on our system
so our chef DK is downloaded now let's
install it
so guys this is the version of chef TK
that you have downloaded so make sure
this is exactly what you type down here
too
so great our chef DK is installed so
basically our installation for the
workstations done right now but just so
you understand how the flow is we'll
also write a sample recipe on our
workstation so before we do that let's
first create a folder my folder named
chef repo
basically the chef repository and let's
move into this folder okay so we're in
next what we need to do is as I
mentioned earlier all your recipes will
be within a cookbook so let's create a
folder which will hold all our cookbooks
and let's move into the stew okay so our
next stage is to create the actual
cookbook within which will have our
recipe so the command for creating the
cookbook is chef generate cookbook
sample because the samples the name of
my cookbook so guys please notice here
cookbooks is the directory that I
created which will hold all our
cookbooks and your cookbook is the
keyword so sample is that one cookbook
that we are creating under our folder
cookbooks
and I cookbooks being created great so
that's done moving into a cookbook
okay so when a cookbook sample was
created automatically there's this
hierarchical structure associated with
it so let's have a look at this
hierarchical structure to understand
what our cookbook sample exactly is
before we move on so the command for
looking at a hierarchical structure is
tree so as you see here within our
cookbook we have a folder recipes and
under this this the default dot RB
recipe this is where we'll be creating
our recipe so we'll just alter the
content of default RB so let's move on
to finally writing our recipes so we'll
move into this recipes folder first
so now we'll open a recipe default @rb
in G edit
so the recipe for this particular demo
is to install the httpd package on our
client node that is basically your
Apache server and will also be hosting a
very simple webpage so let's begin
so the recipes in chef is written in
Ruby so I will explain you the recipe in
a while
okay so the first line is where you
install httpd the second line for
service is where you start or enable the
httpd service on that line note that's
our first task the second part where we
need to create our webpage so this is
the part where your web page will be
stored if you've written any HTML file
previously you know that this is
probably like a default path where our
web pages are created
yep that's it so this is the content
that will be displayed on your web page
if everything works right and I'm pretty
sure it will so now we can save our SP
and that's done
close your GA so now that we have
created the recipe all our work at the
workstation is completed the next thing
we do is we move on to the server so as
I mentioned earlier we'll be using the
server as a service on the cloud so go
to your browser and here just type
manage dot chef dot IO so this is the
homepage of your chef server click here
to get started we need to first create
an account for using the chef server is
completely free we just need to give our
email id and if you are the details it's
in fact a lot like creating an account
on Facebook or Instagram
fill in all the details check the Terms
of Service box
so the next thing you need to do is go
back to your inbox and verify your email
id so I have my inbox opened here on my
Windows machine so this is my inbox
you'd have received a mail from chef
software just click on this link to
verify it and create your password and
that's done so let's continue this on
our workstation machine so type in your
username and password
so the first time you log into your chef
server you'll have this pop-up appear
where you need to create a new
organization so create your organization
so this organization is basically the
name that will be associated with a
collection of the client machines first
thing you do go to your administration
tab and download the starter kit so guys
when you're doing this part make sure
that you're on your workstation that is
your opening your chef server on the
workstation because you need this folder
to be installed here
you save the file so this gets
downloaded so the chef star ticket is
the key to connecting your workstation
with the server and the server with the
node so basically it has a tool called
knife which will come across later in
our demo this knife is what takes care
of all the communication and the
transferring of cookbooks between the
three machines in our case the two
machines the workstation and the node
and the one server so let's go back to
our u directory so our chef starter zip
file is within our Downloads folder what
we do first is will move the zip folder
into our cookbooks folder and then we'll
unzip it there because a cookbooks
folder is the one that contains the
recipe and that is where we require
knife tool command to be present so we
can send this recipes over to the server
so we'll just check the contents of our
cookbooks right now to ensure that our
chef started our zip file is within the
cookbooks
yep so it's here so next thing we do is
we need to unzip this folder
great so that unzipped and this means
that a workstation and a server are now
linked so we just need to use the knife
command tool to transfer or to upload
our s piece which we created on the
workstation onto the server so before we
execute this command we need to move
into a cookbooks directory as you know
that is where we unzipped our chef
starter kit so that is where our knife
command is present too
and now let's execute the knife command
so it's nice cookbook upload and sample
so as you probably recall sample is the
name of the cookbook that we created and
within sample we created our recipe
which is default dot RB
so we uploading the entire cookbook on
to the server execute the command
great so our cookbooks uploaded now
let's check this on our server so move
to your browser where you opened your
chef server and go to policy so here you
go this is the cookbook we uploaded
sample and it's the first time we
uploaded it so the version zero point
one point zero the first version now
what you would notice is if you go to
the notes tab there are no notes present
so if you have no nodes you basically
have no machine to execute your
cookbooks and the nodes are not seen
right now because we have not configured
them yet so that's the next thing we
need to do all this so far was done on
your master machine now we'll move on to
the node machine so before moving on
let's just check the IP of our node
machine so that's our IP note this down
somewhere and now we move back to our
workstation
as we already saw that we uploaded a
sample workbook next thing we need to
make sure that a server and node are
able to communicate with each other so
again we use the knife tool for this to
the command here is knife bootstrap and
enter the IP address of your node which
we just check
we'll be logging in there so we'll be
using the node as the root user and then
we also need to specify our root
password for the node and we give a name
to this node so this is the name by
which we'll be identifying our node at
the server
so as you have probably noticed here we
are using the term SSH which is a secure
shell so it basically provides a channel
of secure communication between two
machines in an unsafe environment ok so
it's done so if your command has
executed right which in our case as we
can see has a chef server and a chef
node must be able to communicate with
each other so if this is so we should be
able to send the cookbook that we
previously uploaded from a workstation
onto the server now from a server to our
node so to do that before we move on to
the node machine we need to go back to
our chef's server let's refresh this
page and as you see here previously
under the notes tab we did not have any
node mention now we do
chef node which is the node we wanted to
identify our node by which is a centrist
platform and that's our IP so it's
active for to us that's the uptime last
check in the last time we checked into
our node was a minute back and yeah
that's pretty much it
so now we'll create a run list and we'll
add a sample to this run list so just
click on your node and you'll see the
small arrow here at the end
click on that edit run list and under
available recipes we have a cookbook
sample present so drag and drop this to
the current run list and accept it ok so
now that we updated our run list our
recipe is sent to our node what we next
need to do is that we need to execute
this at our node so now we'll move on to
our node machine
chef's client is the command to execute
yon
so while this recipe is executing you
can see what exactly is happening a
recipe was to install httpd package
first which is your Apache server so the
first line that's done and it's up to
date the second line it's enabled third
line the service is started and the
fourth line is where your contents
created for the webpage at this very
location so by the look of this
everything should work fine so how do we
check this we can just go to our browser
and the search bar just type localhost
and there you go so I have ste TPD
package which is the patches server is
installed and our sample web page is
also hosted congratulations on
completing the chef demo if you have any
doubts regarding the demo please put
them in the comment section below and
we'll definitely reply to you so I hope
you guys really liked the video if you
did please hit the like button also
subscribe to our channel if you haven't
so yet we have more installation videos
coming up so stay tuned this is anjali
signing off see you all next time
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here